welcome to this video for around eight
of the candidates tournament the first
round where we have yeah the return
matches so to say and we have a very
important one right here for this video
aronian playing honored the two leaders
meet each other and what's very
important to keep in mind is that Anand
has won in the first round of the
tournament against uronian so he is
leading 1-0 in this mini match which
means that in case of a draw here a nerd
retains the lead despite both players
having equal points he is better on the
try break which is some the individual
round against result against each other
okay let's see what happens aronian
playing c4 and Alan playing c6 yeah he's
some offering a sloth defense and we see
that it looks like we get a sloth and
yeah Here I am yeah you think that white
only has like four moves here I mean
technically some more but III 1g3 both
we have seen in this tournament and
uronian has played that for example
against stone and Drake in getting a
very good position and here he played
quite quite a surprising move we played
3 b3 and he played it instantly yeah
that's a very very rare move and
certainly something that takes am
honored out of his preparation like
instantly yeah what's the idea the
general idea to cover the pawn on c4
with the Queen it's not it's not new of
course it happens in all kinds of in all
kinds of openings in the Queen porn
English territory and we can easily
transpose to known positions let's say
for example if black plays Knight f6
and wide well d forward instantly
transport us love but let's say he plays
g3 leg place g6 right place d4 and we
have the goon fealty and chateau all of
a sudden just one possible thing or this
could be another way to play disposing
to catalan there are many possible
transpositions but aren't after thinking
for a while decided to play the sharpest
move he played a d5 deform which at
least them to me um looked a bit strange
first because the combination of this d5
yeah let's say D 5 D for nc6 looks a bit
weird but on the other hand what does
widescreen doing must be three in the
structure this is perfectly okay what
island played it still surprised me a
bit as after e3 which are only unplayed
pretty much instantly as after you three
black now is you're almost forced to
sacrifice upon the thing is ok this is
hanging you need to do something about
it you have no peace like 96 to cover
the pawn so what is there you can only
play c5 here or you can take now but the
capture after just recapturing it looks
like some our Black has made no move at
this game and why does night out and D
for coming with the big center well the
Queen only three is not brilliant but
it's not hurting you and the old
structure is good for wide so you
basically have to play c5 this was clear
of any play d4 that you would know place
he fine and yeah this is of course
sacrificing upon check and Aronian just
grabbed it Queen B 5 check looks a bit
strange all those hurt equis moves but
okay heads winning upon knight c6 that
was the idea of the sleep something like
I know be should be 7s it's just worse
version of the game you need the knight
on c6 yeah the Queen took of course
everything else makes no sense and
aronian played this on instantly the
clock times are accurate i have saw the
live feed of that Queen c5 and now e5 so
winning a temple on the Queen yeah no
choice what needs to go here Queen D 5mm
it looks crazy anyway but after Quincy
seven black will get very important
temple so complete this is useless need
to go here and yeah now it's interesting
on a plate a six which is probably okay
you need to get rid of this this pin and
here ironia played Queen to be three you
still playing quickly he was obviously
in a preparation here well under this of
course working it out over the body
hadn't anticipated quit b3 and in any
way this much as this much is clear um
and I think here actually here we
already have the first critical
situation of this game very early um I'm
played Bishop to c5 which seems okay
well but he also had to move Knight to
instead of that Knight to f6 and this is
maybe an maybe a sharper way to play and
more interesting um yeah what is blacks
compensation actually in this position
he has lost upon but on the other hand
what he does have he has very easy
development of his pieces yeah the
bishop here can go out somewhere this
Bishop can go out on any of those
squares not not clear what black has
gained a possible good square on c5 for
the night in this kind of situation and
of course he's got some dominance in the
same
the ponds yard ones black certainly has
some compensation this is quite clear
why does lost yeah this is these are
quite some moves that he has invested
means the Queen five times out of eight
the first moves so I black certainly has
some compensation but look at this
position concretely what is right going
to play here and it would be very
interesting to learn what aronian has
had planned there because it really
looks like this quick maybe this quick
play was was part of a huge bluff but I
think he should have and I think he had
pin some idea what you would do now I'm
not quite sure what exactly because it
looks like and this to me that black has
very serious compensation here um we can
look at a few moves start with the bad
ones Bishop e2 this is just very bad
because of d3 very important feature of
this night you get any form and this is
just just good for black you can try to
to justify something like that if you
like but here I mean black has got a
piece there White has got three pawns
for that the black has very active
position so this should be a good for
black Bishop e2 is a silly move anyway
but i just want to show that this is not
possible of course this is entirely out
of the question so what actually do you
play against Knight f6 yeah a natural
move would be d3 after that let has this
check and this is quite strong already
if you know interpose something like
that this pawn him it's very tough to
defend
yeah you can like that but what they're
doing now about the pond the computer
already wants to play move lakini to
which shows that widest and dire straits
IAM um the same actually applies if you
play this move which looks entirely sick
anyway but still i'd like to clean show
it and one okay and this is just a
terrible bishop d2 of course is the most
natural move after that jela can just
exchange and go for that oops come on
and this is also quite nice how do you
defend III again add d4 i mean i have
this under control black i can just grab
on default and here it is already
difficult to defend so Knight f6 I don't
know it's d3 is really the answer Bishop
before it's a good play what was
erroneous idea maybe just to take but
after that it's interesting um black and
who has two interesting ways to play he
can play very simple chest like
capturing with that and just claim that
this is a compensation because of the
space advantage um yeah he probably has
enough compensation I'm pretty sure
about that something I just put some
moves on the board to illustrate the
general idea yeah he will simply develop
quickly and gain time who aren't doing
that like that now let's say look here
and be five this is a compensation which
is in a way let's say it's a positional
compensation strategical nature not like
a quick meeting attack similar how you
sometimes get it and let's say the
marshal attack off the rope some
long-term initiative that's what black
gets he also can consider the movie for
which is the sharper option and also
interesting on right now must play d5
there
no other move you cannot play something
like that this night has nowhere to
return a small you must play defy for
your question and here it's interesting
on black could try just to capture now
Bishop to c5 this is very very dangerous
for white it's me it's possible that
Aronian had somehow prepared or looked
at this so deeply that he was could be
relatively certain to to defend this in
case and would have come up with that
but it's it's a really dangerous
position for white um if white for
instance takes here which looks
exceptionally greedy but so there's only
seven and while something like that is
completely completely unplayable for
white you can actually play this funny
move after Bishop e3 takes check we get
to a position where black has sacrificed
the rook but Bishop d7 as threatened to
win the Queen and this is actually
impossible to to avoid you can give the
Queen like that but this also leads to a
strong attack for black it seems that in
this critical position here why
shouldn't take but play deform to gain a
bit of time and it might continue like
that Bishop takes d4 and Bishop e3 yeah
and yeah well we could continue that for
forever it's a very sharp position that
allows for interesting play I'm a simple
the thing that I can do is just to take
and
check check this might be a line that is
safe enough to to claim that white is
okay here maybe maybe this is this is
okay yeah they were interesting ideas
and in case of Knight f6 but Donna
didn't play that he played Bishop to c5
yeah not bad but night f6 it looked a
little bit more to the point I think
okay d 3 plate 9 f six ed four so what
Aronian is trying to do is he sets up a
position that from the bone structure is
very similar to the so called check
benoni like the czech republic not the
check as in checking the king and the
Czech benoni is a black eye opening I
can I can show you this it's very it's
really essential to get some idea what's
going on the check benoni is like that
yeah look at this structure got those
this configuration in the center and
black ass this pieces set in a somewhat
passive but solid way not a bad opening
for blankets not brilliant but it's
playable and now I have a look at the
game check ya hear it's very comparable
white has this structure and Bishop 1 e
2 and white and black has yeah this the
the the structure is also comparable but
he doesn't have a/c porn simply like a
mrs. the C porn and what does he
actually do have in return yeah he has
some gained a bit of time so it is a
closed position but he has gained a bit
of time and what he also did gain is the
c5 square for the night like that and
this is actually a pretty serious
business as this is the best square
possibly available for night in the
structure it would support pressure
against from from here it pressurizes t3
and also has a look on e4 which might
also be target with f5 yeah check Bishop
before check playground and 92 yeah a5
this was a an interesting way to go he
wants to play possibly a form and with
this check he also has cleared the way
for the night yeah Aronian castled 97
and queen 21 yeah he basically
voluntarily retreats as 95 as is coming
anyway yeah until island has retreated
the bishop he wants to have this
opportunity at some at some point and
three pairs night c5 of course this is
the main idea if you play 95 immediately
well a 3 it's nothing you really want to
have don't want to take on d 2 so this
prepares the occupation of the squares
by the Knights 91 now played by Arun
young yeah here the thing is why it is
really in somewhat in a somewhat passive
position and yeah what what can you do
an idea that that I had to to get things
coordinated is the night be one I know
it looks weird to undeveloped completely
but it is a really really close position
the idea is that after night c 5 i'm
going to travel all the way to be 52
this weekend square um but have a look
at this night a three and then possibly
f5 something like that is certainly
quite quite good compensation for black
call upon
you have from a good target on d3 and
why it still has some passive pieces I
don't know night be one seems very slow
Aronian played this one that that has
multiple ideas it protects not this it
protects d3 in case of a future tech by
a 95 on I before and it also prepares
this typical exchange I'd a maneuver to
get rid of this week Bishop on e to this
passive bishop um yeah Mighty One yeah
now night c5 was played yeah in term he
aronian went from the move Knight to be
three trying to challenge the c5 night
yeah what else is there and what about
Bishop g4 this is a move you always need
to check in this type of structure um I
guess that lack is probably going to
play a 4 and just try to gain more space
and ask right and how are you going to
develop now yeah probably white should
will take now I don't really see move
it's a really somewhat passive cannot
miss this night this has no squares
probably just taken something like that
and yeah here black has some really
promising compensation it's got b5 as a
possibility to even open up the Queen
side and yeah what exactly is why doing
here it's not so clear how to how to
even a develop nicely you can play we
are very slow type of moves again like
that but you get hit by a 5 and what is
this everything's on the back rank the
bid weird yeah go here
to play at five it's a it's very tricky
to play aronia didn't play Bishop g4 he
has mentioned went for this a 93 move to
challenge the night on c5 yeah and I
didn't want to exchange he went to a 6
with the idea to just play a form and
then go back to c5 a very typical way of
playing yeah and our only on our plate
right back to d2 this control its a four
so that a four is not possible yeah none
played 95 and you get a nasty suspicion
yes in fact you are right they played
night be 39 86 92 and it was a job I
repetition so very anti-climatic is this
a word way to finish this game of the
two leaders with a quick draw um yeah
what how can you assess this this now
here I think that the problem is that
white really has a passive position
that's that's very much clear this whole
preparation by aronia didn't really
didn't really work out so well I mean
like clearly has a very good
compensation and the question is
actually yeah how if you start and look
at it from White's perspective how would
you actually not play 92 here yeah you
can try and move like f a four block it
I mean but now you're your queen ciders
nope this arrow is useless now the Queen
side is completely frozen on those two
squares black and black and play
directly like f5 or you can decide to
flick in a move like that just covering
everything then maybe rook a 7 + f5
black has multiple ways to
to advance if I it's really ugly move so
you can try something different here
yeah but sorry when when when we looked
at this position and I analyzed a bit of
that this is the only really move that I
can think of but it is it is still not
an attractive position and yeah on the
other hand put are not have played on to
be honest actually I rather see a man
playing on in this position then then
then I uronian just if you look at the
the position itself black could have
tried to to play on but as I explained
in the in the introduction of this video
with this win that are not had scored in
the first turn of this tournament he is
ahead in the individual tie-break so on
it's it's like this drawing means that
Anna does not like scoring just 0.5
points have a point but it's more like
0.7 7.5 here it's like a little bit of
extra on top because it means that he
will be ahead of ronnian in case of
equal points at the end so he could have
played on I mean but it's not so
clear-cut that black is substantially
better I'm just saying that it's a very
comfortable position with your with your
initiative for other porn but on the
other hand it's also very understandable
that drew draw suited him just fine and
aronian I guess simply didn't like the
position very much as it is really
really passive and consider it if you
place on here with wide and tries to
somehow wriggle out of this pest passive
position yeah we can easily make a
mistake and and probably lose the game
and while losing would
been terrible this would have meant that
honored is on plus free aronian back on
+1 so he would have be one point behind
and also often the tiebreak so he would
have needed to score one and a half
point more in the rest of the tournament
from a tactical tournament tactics type
of you I can very much understand the
draw but of course it's a bit um a bit
disappointing especially considering
this crazy opening that that we let me
saw him this game it was funny to hear
from nikka in the press conference who
was asked about this game and they said
that queen bee three year and the
following sequence was Soviet you
wouldn't even played in a rapid game and
he thought that Arnold was better in the
final position maybe I don't know I mean
I think that really a black had a very
comfortable compensation but it's I
guess if kramnik would have been black
in this position in Arnold shoes he
would have taken the draw as well it's
not like he would have risked it all too
who's somehow somewhere gain gain a
point from that all right i hope you
enjoyed the coverage anyway thanks for
watching